bitcoin butchery cryptocurrencies
struggle to regain ground after losses
not seen in years what prompted the
sell-off and is the crisis a game
changer this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the show i'm sami
zaydan well the crypto gold rush is
going through another dip but this time
it's gone so low
some are warning it may not stop many
digital currencies have seen their
values reach zero that's knocked a lot
of confidence out of the market creating
a domino effect reaching all the way to
the top
the mother of them all bitcoin is in
trouble two major trading platforms have
dropped it one cited technical problems
and the other so-called crypto winter
meaning the current extreme market
conditions well as investors become
increasingly nervous more have been
selling off their coins
pretty scary times in the bitcoin space
but actually not something we haven't
seen before uh this is an asset that
went down 94
back in 2011 and came back from the dead
it went down 84 85 percent after the
peak in 2013 to the trough of late 2014
early 2015 and then again went down i
believe about 85 percent from 19700 to
around 31.50 if i recall in december of
2018.
you have to be seventy percent lucky and
thirty percent knowledgeable to win in
this market if you are in the right
place at the right time there is no way
you can win and it's not like five times
ten times or two times profit it's
almost 100 times 500 times a thousand
times there is no state no institution
no organization that gives you this kind
of profit you just have to be lucky
actually
well the more people sell bitcoin the
less it's worth people have been selling
big time in november the crypto coin
reached a record high value of nearly 70
000 us dollars but in the following
months it started going down reaching 35
000 in january it took another blow in
early may falling below thirty thousand
and by june it had lost another ten
thousand dollars dropping below its
benchmark value of twenty thousand
[Music]
well let's bring our guests into the
show we have joining us from nairobi
alican satu an investor and ceo at rich
management
in london naim aslam is chief market
analyst at avatrade and in dublin brian
lucy professor of international finance
and commodities at trinity business
school
welcome to you all let me start with
professor brian then what prompted the
sell-off in the first place brian
well
bitcoin and other cryptos and we tend to
use them you know indistinguishably as
you said it's the
you know the granddaddy of them all and
where it leads
the best follow has been suffering from
some weakness since really the end of
last year if not before
what's really knocked bitcoin i think
and and the rest of them has been the
fact that
as
the global economic environment economic
and geopolitical environment has become
more and more
uncertain we've got supply chain issues
not just from the
russian invasion of ukraine but also
from chinese
policies around covert we have
a problem with regards to
the likelihood of quantitative
tightening in other words unwinding the
the wall of money that was poured into
the global economy
uh with the consequent inflation issues
coming from
both that and from the uh the war
all of these have made the global
risk environment much more risky and
what we've seen is that
the real reason why many of these
cryptos crypto assets they're not really
cryptocurrencies
showed such an increase was a desire for
yield at the very top of your show there
you were talking to people saying well
you can get 100 retire 100 times return
but you only get those kind of massive
returns in exchange for massive risk
and what we've seen is that as the
appetite for risk has
decreased
as things have got more uncertain
people investors have been moving in
general back towards more safe havens
but hang on brian let me jump in here
and ask i thought the whole
mantra we were told about
cryptocurrencies is that
people put their money into them to
actually protect themselves from
inflation and answers
that was if you look at the the
countries with the top investments in
bitcoin were countries which had very
big inflationary problems how did
inflation go from being a driver towards
to a detractor from
uh cryptocurrency because they aren't
i mean this is of course what you would
be told if you're trying to sell an
asset that's hyper risky
you'll find a use for it find a use case
we've won precisely these are not
currencies we must put this phraseology
to bed these are crypto assets
we've precisely won in situation in el
salvador where we've had a natural
experiment of running a fiat currency in
fact not even its own currency the
dollar
versus a crypto and every single
asset every every single uh study that
has been done has shown that
there has been incredibly limited usage
of this as a currency
as an asset they're very risky
they have some interesting
characteristics
they're very very volatile that's the
nature of the beast
that volatility if you're on the right
place at the right time can give you a
great return
but they are not
for everybody
they are a hard currency structure in
that many of them have a limited number
of
tokens or satoshis or you know whatever
you can create that can only ever be
created and as a result
there is an inbuilt bias towards
appreciation of
the nominal value but that's not the
same to say that they're a hedge against
inflation right
but it's interesting i mean some
countries i think turkey was one of them
russia was another that was the reason
why we were told people were putting
their money because they were afraid
about cut their local currencies losing
value let's bring in naim
was also the collapse of some of the
other coins like terra usd
did it contribute to what we've seen
happening in the wider digital coin
market i completely can't care with you
when you
are in a new cycle of innovation
technologies blow out like these that do
happen as a market adjust a new reality
a new product
and as you guys were discussing earlier
you know search for a better yield
product obviously created an enormous
amount of a grid in this space
like you could get yield which was
completely unheard of up to 30 or 25
percent
so that created a massive bulb a
bubble around everything so basically
just like how our traditional systems uh
financial systems work where one bank is
pretty much using the money from another
bank and then you have that domino
effect already taking place in the
crypto world because a lot of these
yield players they they come from
traditional markets now they are not
your you know your ico people who have
no idea although they do still exist in
the market but they're using the same
sort of mentality so once that pool
begins to flow between the institution
of course there's a massive risk of
dominant effect one institution falling
or one startup or one particular project
falls and then you have other projects
coming on the back of that as well so
we've seen that in the case of celsius
even now blockify which was another
yield based project
being rescued by ftx another american
exchange so the story kind of really
goes on
now going back to some of the points
that you guys were discussing earlier
and i just wanted to add two important
things to them
look i'm not saying that bitcoin is
still not an hedge i'm against
uncertainty i'm not saying that bitcoin
is not hedge against inflation
but what i
do think that it is plausible to ask
this particular question is the
reputation has massively been impacted
because as brian mentioned earlier you
know we are living in damage time
absolutely absolutely i mean inflation
is at 40 deca for 40 years high right
four decade high we should we should see
bitcoin prices completely you know
like literally soaring on the back of
that we've seen the evidence of gold
prices at least showing stability when
dollar index is already at its
multi-year high so we we see that
usually when the federal reserve
tightens the monetary policy we see you
know gold prices moving to the downside
but gold prices are very much stable
because of inflation and in terms of a
bitcoin we should we should have seen a
lot more
buying really happening now the same
argument goes for the uncertainty in the
market as well with the risk of climate
the markets falling you know now that
correlation between bitcoin which is a
relationship either moving positive or
negative between bitcoin and the stock
market is very much positive what does
that entail that means that bitcoin is
very much acting as a riskier asset or
as a risk on asset if i
if i say that that and it's this more
appropriate statement not as a risk off
asset because we don't see bitcoin
moving to the upside when stock markets
are moving in the other direction right
so
ali i guess what we're saying so far
here is that
there was bitcoin or digital currencies
crypto currencies were simply
a mechanism for wild
gains
a lot of risk and when it wasn't
delivering that kind of gain anymore the
bubble was too big and it just had to
burst at some point
i couldn't agree more it reminds me of
that quote by hunter s thompson life
should not be a journey to the grave
with the intention of arriving safely in
a pretty and well preserved body but
rather skidding broadside in a cloud of
smoke thoroughly used up totally worn
out and loudly proclaiming while what
arrived
we've had the ride the ride is over now
um
essentially bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
were more of what were not the antidote
to central bank bubbles they were a
symptom of it
and in the last two three years the era
of free money the era of you know the
trampoline the idea that you could
generate those returns that were
described at the beginning of your show
the fear of missing out fomo
you know all all um all were conducive
for this
extraordinary bubble that we saw develop
and unfortunately the bubble is now
deflated i think we've still got
considerable downside it is no longer
investible by any institution we had
that that that period when the likes of
elon were piling into it and then
promoting all kinds of other coins like
doji coin
but in any institution
now reporting bitcoin or even a crypto
currency on its balance sheet is going
to find its cfo shown the door you know
in a blink of an eye so i think what
we're seeing now is really uh the end of
an era it was exciting um uh some people
made a ton of money more people have
lost it
but essentially this this gig is over
all right those are just big words ali
the gig is over i can see naima's
shaking his head in disagreement so i
want to give him a chance to come in
here
with the different perspective on this
is the party over name are you packing
up
and
i never and i really put my money where
my mouth is because i'm literally for
disclaimer purposes i'm a big holder
and i hold bitcoin in my wallet and i'm
continuous and i'll continue to do that
even at a lower price even though
even though what ally and what brian was
saying you know a lot of this was just
driven by pure speculation pure greed
and the era of easy money people
borrowing money to buy
digital currencies that they perhaps
couldn't really afford that's over now
there weren't so much buying money if i
could jump borrowing money go ahead it
was that with
with money sloshing around the system
uh you're going to have a situation
where it's going to fly into all sorts
of areas where you can get a return
particularly when you've got relatively
low inflation as we've had over the last
five seven years and
it's not just bitcoin it's not just nfts
there's been a whole host of other
assets where there have been rocket
price appreciation but it is one of the
one of the assets which are deflating
because there's not enough money
throwing around now
well it's not so much that i think it's
because it's it's it's you know the
first one that really deflated was dnft
because the idea that you know a picture
of a monkey and a hat would have
inherent value other than being a
picture of a monkey in a house was
always completely bonkers
these crypto assets have some i i kind
of disagree with madame lagarde i i
think what these are
are
valueless but not worthless they have a
worth to people who
believe in the need for a parallel
decentralized
monetary exchange system and who are
happy to accept
the incredibly high volatility
now does that mean they're worth 50 60
70 000 euro or is it 50 60 000 50 60
euro there's probably a floor which is
above zero
but it's i think probably an awful lot
well an awful long way away from 15 or
17 000
so
i think the era has gone out in the
sense of you know the wild days that was
always going to happen
once these were never going to be a
currency and they never were going to be
a currency
then they were only ever going to be an
asset
if you're going to have an asset then
that asset is ultimately if it becomes
big enough
be regulated
we've seen increasing regulation okay
yeah i know we just finished my point
you're seeing increasing regulation and
discussion of regulation and the
increasing maturity of these markets
with things like etfs and options and
futures
once that happened as led they became
inextricably linked to the remainder of
the financial system which they hadn't
been before and therefore became as was
said a risk-on asset all right a name
you are presenting the opposite
perspective and i interrupted you so let
me give you the chance to complete the
thought about why the party is still on
for you
sure thank you so like if you are
talking about you know excessive money
printing money qe whatever you want to
call it deflated entire space look at
look at nasdaq look at smp500 look at
dow john everything is pretty much
crushing but not to the extent but if
you look at the individual stocks the
meme stocks and everything else they
were obviously and
clearly they were very much pumped
because of excessive money from the
retail side of the institution
bitcoin is a different beast as i've
mentioned to you previously it has a
history
of coming back very rapidly back to his
all-time highs
and i think my only concern in relation
to this particular one is that i wanted
to see that credibility coming back a
little bit meaning bitcoin needs to
re-establish yourself as a ra as as a
hedge against uncertainty as a hedge
against inflation those are the two
primary concerns in relation to that but
having said that i think given where the
price is currently and then yes there
are odds that perhaps we may see and
move further to the downside perhaps
thirty to fifteen thousand that is where
i see the floor or a massive so you
don't really name that
you know we heard many of those calls
and then the simple answer to that is
just listen from one and then let it go
from the other side because it's all
about filtering through the noise and
then looking through that what is the
really future for this one all right
all right let me ask ali do you agree
with that have we approached the floor
here
look i i think um you know we're going
to see face ripping short covering
rallies um you know because when
something falls like this you're always
going to get these very vicious bounces
but i think you know what we've seen now
is is a turning point
it was exponential to the upside it's
now exponential to the downside i mean
if you can you can make an argument that
could go down as low as a thousand where
it was somewhere in 2016. okay it might
not go to zero but it's going a lot
lower and i think uh you know it's a
feedback loop and
at a more macro level
um as i said earlier this was a symptom
of central bank bubbles it was not an
antidote to them
and now we've we're exiting the era of
central bank bubbles um it's impossible
for western governments to run their
economies by just printing
endless amounts of money and this is why
we've got inflation lifting off
and what it tells us is the world
understands that the hedge against
inflation
is hard or soft assets like food
like oil like wheat things you can't
print
and essentially those are the true
hedges and i think this was a wonderful
delirious episode and delirium can last
for quite a long time and it did last
for for for a very long time but
ultimately i go back to that south sea
prospectus
where it was said you know there are
many
this is a scheme the carrying on of an
undertaking of great advantage but
nobody knows what it is and frankly to
this day nobody really does all right i
love the variety and perspective we're
getting here very different
request can i make it very briefly then
we want to go to brian very briefly yes
then
go ahead aslan briefly
sorry i'm saying can i make a request
and that is let's have three of us back
here towards the end of this year and
look at the price action all right
that's that's a good one all right
somebody's gonna be right and someone's
to be wrong um brian the fact that we're
seeing institutional investors dumping
their digital coins right now this the
fact we're seeing crypto exchanges
announcing layoffs is that a sign that
things are not going back to where they
were not anytime soon at least
yeah i think
you know we're we're we're moving into a
different environment how long that will
last
you know another old expression is the
market can stay illogical longer than
you can stay liquid and flip that around
the market can stay logical longer than
you can stay illogical in in the context
of kryptos
until such time as we move
through this inflationary era which is
partially driven by a wall of money and
partially driven by supply shocks
until we move to an environment where
yields are pushed down on traditional
things like you know government stocks
and commodities such as wheat you know
all the boring boring stuff
then there will be an appetite again for
hyper risky assets and and that's where
the remaining crypto assets and there
will be some
will will come back and have their day
in the sun again along with something
else
but they're not crypto currencies let's
stop using that phrase
they're just assets they're crypto
assets they they are not never have been
and never will be a substitute for fiat
currency all right the only substitute
for the efforts we're going to get will
be central bank digital currencies all
right whatever we're going to call them
name
is this a turning point in terms of at
least regulation that going forward they
will now need to be regulated in a very
different way
that's an excellent
question now the answer to that
particular question is look at this
crypto landscape today do we have more
regulations in comparison to two or
three years ago or when was the last
crash happen the answer to that one is
clearly yes because we have many
exchanges which are very much regulated
in the united states and in various
different jurisdictions and even till
the state acquisitions are only
happening so that those exchanges can
operate under the licenses under the
regulations of that particular
jurisdiction
so i think the current blow out in
terror luna is gonna only in or in the
in the high yield space is only going to
invite more regulators to come and
provide that security who's going to
provide that regulation name and what
will it mean for what was supposed to be
a very free-flowing
decentralized
i don't want to use the word currency
because i know brian doesn't like it but
you know what i mean
i i think there are still so many
different proposals on the table who is
really going to provide that but there
is one thing very clear
as human being you want it to be
governed by one single entity rather
whatever jurisdiction you are
and and that goes back and that's that's
why the fear currencies are already
working or any other currencies because
you have a central advantage over
governments which can really come in and
then they can they can they can
initiate some uh
phenomenons like you know bank run they
can stop that they can say that okay you
can know you cannot withdraw more than
300 euros or 250 euros during the pigs
crisis right we've seen that we do not
have that currently in the crypto space
but now
yes we do see
some initial reactions and actions by
these particular companies such as
celsius and few others where they're
saying okay you know what all of
israel's are suspended when the
companies are still afraid that's
desperation
that's desperation because the whole
point of having decentralized
peer-to-peer finance is that it isn't
regulated that the market finds its own
regulation
stopping people from transacting on
unregulated markets is not regulation
it's
people trying to prop up liquidity
positions for you know for perfectly
sensible and sane reasons
okay the reality is moreover this goes
it'll be regulated by the sec it'll be
regulated by the fsa it can be regulated
by the ecb it'll form part of some
successor to mfid it'll be just another
boring but very risky set of assets all
right i'm afraid we are out of time i
know that we've got
plenty of different perspectives on this
and uh perhaps as name said
we'll come back and talk about this all
again when either you know the coin has
gone up or down
but for now thanks so much guys it's
been a great discussion
thank you so thank our guests
aslam and brian lucy
and thank you two for watching you can
see the show again anytime by visiting
our website aljazeera.com
for further discussion head over to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle there is at aj inside story
from me sami zaydan and the whole team
here in doha for now is goodbye